welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and one division is pointing a lot
of fingers that want to maximoff herself
as the villain of the series
and yes she is clearly an active thread
casting some kind of spell over westview
but i think we're all smart enough to
know better than to take a mystery
series at its word less than halfway
through
especially when its own stars are saying
a huge surprise cameo is coming at the
end
and especially when a shifty ass suit
comes sliding in with a grin and a
punchable chin
swords acting director tyler hayward
definitely has some kind of secret plan
and i definitely have a solid hunch as
to what it is
spoiler warning in case i'm right or in
case i accidentally ruined the
reputation of a perfectly respectable
private citizen
doubt it so hayward worked for sword
alongside monica rambo sword founder
maria rambo
died during the blip opening up a
vacancy that hayward filled based on his
attitude toward monica he clearly is
pretty uncomfortable with her return
knowing that his job definitely should
have gone to her monica's first question
out of the gate is about sword's
astronaut program but
hayward says it's dwindled due to half
his astronauts getting dusted
and now they've lost their nerve instead
hayward suggests sword has shifted to
new projects in robotics nanotech and ai
and then he claims maria rambo's final
orders were to ground
monica with earthbound missions should
she ever return which
is a bit weird because why would you
assume anyone would return if you think
you're in the middle of the rapture
anyway
he then assigns monaco to jimmy woo's
missing person case in west view
so some suspicious things to point out
about hayward here he knows that
monica's gonna return to work that day
so he clears her through the facility
drive-in gate that i assume they have
but he still doesn't activate her badge
at the front desk does that not seem
like a bit of a power move to make sure
hayward himself would have to escort
monica through the facility
and to keep her from snooping around to
see what he's working on
and there's this tense exchange we have
an agent today
and you look old as though or to
translate the subtext here
you look too young to be here little
lady is your father nearby
you look like you just drank out of the
wrong holy grail crypt keeper are you
literally a demon from hell
now some of us hail ladies have said
hayward might be
mephisto himself i did point out in the
breakdown that his wall frames are kind
of arranged in a hexagonal ring there
might be something to that there might
not but i gotta say
i would be surprised if hayward himself
is revealed to be
marvel's devil nothing against josh
stanberg the guy's a great actor but
i just feel like they would save a role
as big as mephisto
for a bigger name unless they end up
doing a thing where stanberg's face
melts away into the face of a different
actor you know like how they did colin
farrell dirty turning him into johnny
depp and fantastic beasts
now paul bettany has said a few times
that there is a huge name actor coming
later this series whom he had always
wanted to work with
a cameo that elizabeth olsen recently
said was on par with luke skywalker's
cameo
in the mandalorian but before i continue
thank you to keeps for sponsoring this
video
losing your hair can be a bummer sure it
makes your professor x cosplay easier
but what if you want to do wolverine or
cyclops instead and your wig budget is
low
well two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
with keeps it is easier and more
affordable to get treatment for your
hair loss and help you keep the hair
that you have
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out
there but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy and you don't have to go to a
doctor's office you can do it all from
the comfort of your own home
you meet with a doctor online and they
ship the treatment right to you
every three months so you don't have to
wait in the line at a pharmacy find out
why keeps has more five-star reviews
than
any of its competitors and nearly 100
000 men trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication if you are
noticing that you are losing your hair
do something about it for a limited time
go to keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link on the
description to receive 50 off your first
order
so there is totally another mystery man
yet to be revealed in one division and
at the moment i still think it is
probably agnes off-screen but
continuously referenced husband ralph
who also might be the same person as
jimmy woo's missing man from federal
witness protection
who vanished in west view this missing
witness must be
important i don't think it's just gonna
be that mailman despite that weird
diagnosis scene because let's remind
ourselves what jimmy said about him
i have contacted known associates
relatives and let me guess none of them
have seen him either
no none of them have ever heard of him
yeah monica
a witness in federal witness protection
brainwashed his past associates to
forget he ever existed
associates presumably on the west coast
because jimmy wu is from oakland and
that somehow this witness is still doing
this
all the way from new jersey jimmy's own
notes confirm that westview's warping
extends to a
five mile radius explaining the east
view cops and the nearby highway sign
but for those past associates on the
other side of the country to have been
like
obliviated like hermione's parents tells
us that this westview anomaly must have
started with this other person who has
the ability
to brainwash people it started with this
guy not with wanda wanda got brought
into it that's why this missing person's
identity is so important
he and we know it is a male from jimmy's
own words
he is the key to it all but this does
not clear hayward that guy
knows something like there was the way
he cut darcy off already knowing all
about cosmic radiation
my equipment registered an extremely
high level of cmbr
that's relic radiation dating back to
the big bang yeah as if he already knows
what the westview anomaly is and he's
just disappointed to have his fears
confirmed
so here is my current theory with
hayward remember paul bettany claimed
there was a removed endgame post-credits
scene that would have shown wanna
maximoff
pulling out vision's corpse from a
morgue drawer at one point there was
going to be a tag
where you opened a sort of body bag
drawer
and there was the vision kevin kind of
talked to me and said
i just i gotta pull the shots and i was
like
and trailer footage is showing some
unidentified location that looks like
it's got rows and rows of body drawers
i think sword under hayward's directive
scooped up vision's corpse from wakanda
after infinity war
and scavenged it for tech that was the
new
sentient weapon creation that he
referred to with monica
shifted away from manned missions and
refocused on robotics
nanotech ai robotics nanotech ai those
are all
kind of things that are part of vision's
dna but then days after
everyone blipped back and end game wanna
maximoff
steals vision's corpse in her eyes she
was just cradling that body
moments ago she needs closure and so yes
maybe we will see that in-game
scene that betany said was removed this
creates a huge problem for hayward he
would need visions corpse
back and quietly so he cuts a deal with
a
high profile criminal informant let's
call this person
m m and m's partner agnes are capable of
brainwashing people putting them in
trances to make them think things that
are not real
they tell heyward we can trick this
avenger into letting go of this corpse
we're just going gonna brainwash her
into thinking that corpse gave her some
kids and then we'll just extract the
hubby away
so hayward sets us all up he has m
relocated to westview new jersey to lay
this trap for wanda
but em and agnes of course have their
own agenda to hijack wanda's powers for
their own reasons
so agnes contacts wanda saying she knows
of a spell that can bring her beloved
vision back
all wanda has to do is recall a time
with her love
and wanda's mind goes to what she had
spent the past two years doing with
vision on the run
binging tv sitcoms indoors and then boom
not only does wanda think she's in a
sitcom with vision
her sorcery warps reality around her
to make this actually kind of real it
envelops
agnes and m everyone in west view so now
everyone is stuck just playing along
with wanda terrified not knowing how
long this is gonna last meanwhile from
the outside hayward is desperately
trying to end this illusion trying to
keep the lid on his vision operation so
monica doesn't take his job so assuming
this is the mcu's version of house of
the m
as evidenced by the wine bottle
and that brian michael bendis inspired
image of monica
so cool looking who is the m m
plus agnes could be magnus as in house
of magnus the name magneto goes under
in that alternate mutant dominated
reality of house of m
m of course could also be the double
figure mendisto you know my thoughts on
that devil in the details
hell m could even be mysterio master of
illusions
a guy who loves tricking avengers into
thinking they're somewhere they're not
that could be why this series is taking
place before far from home when mysterio
was definitely still alive
though darcy called the westview anomaly
cmbr
cosmic microwave background radiation i
don't think that's the same thing
as binary augmented retroframing not
every spectrum-related acronym is the
same thing also that would be two
mcu titles back to back where it's all
revealed to be barf and to that i would
say
puke hey let me know what you think of
this theory and who you think the big
bad
m of one division is and yes as always i
am wearing our new latest obsession
shirt an
unusual couple limited supply still
available at our merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
me rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
on youtube for breakdowns of everything
one division thank you for watching
you